can we draw a distinction between
authoritarian regimes and communism is
it possible to Steel Man the case that
not all implementations of socialism and
communism would lead to the atrocities
we've seen in the Soviet Union and uh in
China under Mao
like when you in studying all of this
how much blame do you put on the
ideologies on the Marxist ideologies
versus the particular leaders and
dictators well you have to blame the
leaders a lot because they had different
leaders in different countries were uh
different from each other Duke who took
over Czechoslovakia and he tried to
introduce socialism with the human face
in the Prague spring of 1968. he was
like all right we got to do away with
this authoritarianism we gotta have more
free speech he was thinking of
introducing elements of democracy now
then the Russians sent in the tanks but
the point is he certainly was someone
who was like all right this this has got
to stop this is just absolutely crazy
um Khrushchev and Stalin were not the
same animal at all
um so I I think the problem with uh
communism in in the Marxist sense is
that you're going to have an introduced
an element of authoritarianism simply
because you can't have
um economic planning if I don't have a
price mechanism I don't know how price
is what is me knowing as a consumer or a
producer what should be produced or what
had there's a shortage of as prices
increase that's a signal that we have a
shortage here as prices decrease that
means that there's a surplus here but if
I'm setting the price I don't really
have know how much weed I need to
produce if I'm compared to Corn as
compared to shoes as compared to Santa
costumes so that is a big problem the
other issue is if you have one agency
the government having a monopoly on
let's suppose the news like you were
talking about earlier with Twitter it's
going to be really hard to have any kind
of objective discourse because everyone
is going to be working for the same
organization that is going to cause a
problem in terms of having a feedback
mechanism even in the best scenario in
terms of this is a problem this isn't a
problem and when you have a monopoly
which is what a government is I think
people are very familiar with what the
problems happen with Monopoly this lack
of accountability bureaucracies are
faceless and then no one's to blame but
you know uh and yet everyone kind of
suffers as a consequence so it doesn't
necessarily have to be as authoritarian
as stalinism but you can't have have it
a government which is Authority by its
nature be this pervasive
without a strong amount of of Oppression
and same thing with even if you just
have like what's the most socialized
Healthcare you're going to have to make
it illegal for doctors to practice
privately you're going to have to have
rationing so on and so forth now that
might be a price that people are willing
to pay because you can't have infinite
spending on health care right so
something's gonna have to give somewhere
so there is an element of
authoritarianism there and people are
comfortable with that and I can wrap my
head around it but if you're going to
have one organization running literally
everything in society I don't see how
you do that and have any measure of
liberalism